the next Speaker of the House is likely
to come from California if Democrats
take control Nancy Pelosi is expected to
return to the position that she held
from 2007 to 2011
but if Republicans keep the House
Majority Leader Kevin McCarthy is the
favorite to replace retiring Speaker
Paul Ryan Carter Evans is at the
Registrar of Voters office in Santa Ana
California with a look at the state's
bigger role in the midterms Carter good
morning good morning
typically national elections are decided
long before the ballots are counted here
in California but this year is different
some are predicting the future of the
house could be decided right here in
this building now CBS News is following
seven races in the state where
Republican seats might flip the
Democrats and four of them are here in
Orange County the birthplace of Richard
Nixon this has long been considered a
Republican stronghold in a largely
democratic state but that is changing
all four districts being contested today
voted for Hillary Clinton in 2016 and
are populated by a rapidly growing
Latino and Asian immigrant demographic
each of the races is within the polling
margin of error including the highest
profile battle between 30-year
Republican incumbent dana rohrabacher a
staunch ally of President Trump and
Democratic businessman Harley ruda who
has never held an elected office in his
life but if the fate of the house comes
down to California tonight don't expect
the results to be in right away because
of the state's generous voting
provisions here and the popular
popularity of all these mail-in ballots
it could be days or even weeks before
the races are called Norah all right
Carter thank you so much